so with that let's take a look at our  most recent coven 19 numbers here in the  state  301 new cases were added since yesterday  along with 12 more deaths  the state's positivity rate continues to  drop though it is now just above  5 percent a lot of progress so the  majority of those new cases and deaths  were from clark county  the recovery rate remains at 96 percent  if you need to get a coveted test there  are still several locations open this  week  the southern nevada health district is  open monday through friday  the stan fulton building over at unlv  also has appointments this week  and the boulder city fire department is  offering testing all day today  we have more information on those hours  and making an appointment on eight  newsnow dot com